a las elecciones regionales de venezuela
serán vigiladas por observadores de la
unión europea más de tres mil cargos
entre gobernadores alcaldes y concejales
se definirán el próximo 21 de noviembre
nosotros vamos observar todo el proceso
electoral desde la campaña a la
administración electoral al momento de
votación después del recuento de votos
de todo seais reclamaciones en ojai y
produciremos un relatorio que vamos a
entregar la oposición respaldada por
estados unidos participará por primera
vez en las elecciones desde que en 2017
alegarán que los comicios bajo maduro
fueron ilegítimos
es el caso de tomás guanipa que regresó
al país tras dos años en el exilio para
hacerle frente al oficialismo e intentar
ganar la alcaldía de caracas antes no
habían ni siquiera forma de presentarse
porque la gran mayoría de los candidatos
estaban inhabilitados los partidos que
hoy siguen siendo secuestrados inclusive
la unidad no se podía presentar no había
observación internacional es la primera
vez en 15 años que la unión europea
envía observadores electorales a
venezuela la misión que contará hasta
con 100 funcionarios estará presente en
23 de los 24 estados de venezuela solo
dejando a las amazonas por fuera